[Music]
comedian he'll be performing his live
show evening of evening comedy at Union
Hall in Brooklyn on November 26 please
look the very funny Barry Rothbart yes
yes yes I'm so glad you guys are big
fans of mine so you probably know I've
been traveling a bunch I was just in
Baltimore have any you guys been to
Baltimore thank okay if you haven't
Baltimore is like a city from the game
SimCity
right before you lose the game like
there's like pipes bursting and flames
shooting and the mayor's like hey screw
it it's like four stadiums on one block
I was there and I had a near-death
experience what happened was I was
outside of a strip club and I hesitate
to call it a strip club
it was more like moms dancing in the
dark and we were outside and this guy
comes up I don't know who this guy is
comes up to me pulls a gun out points it
in my face and he goes hey is your name
Corey and I'm like no and he goes oh I'm
sorry and he puts it away and walks away
who is this guy with the worst vendetta
ever we see like yeah yeah someone
screwed my wife but what does he look
like I don't know his name's Corey we're
pulling guns on Corey's and like who's
so trusting of honesty that you could
put a gun in someone's face it's like
being like hey what's your favorite
color better not be blue oh it's green
I'm sorry
this vendetta is over I knew you guys
think I look like an adult but I'm 29
and I feel like I start using that
phrase a lot like I'm an adult I should
do blank but it's never for like
constructive things it's never like I'm
an adult I should start opening my mail
it's like I try to figure weird things
out like up until a few days ago this is
true I honestly thought that when you
poop in an airplane they just release it
into the air I thought they're just like
well hope it's Iowa and they like let it
out of the plane no adults make
airplanes I think about what kind of
parent I'm gonna be right and a lot of
people like want to be like their
parents but I know what kind of parent
would it be and it's Liam Neeson from
the movie taken yes he's the greatest
parent of all time his kid gets abducted
he kills like 1/3 of the population of
France in that movie what and he's like
a vague badass like my favorite scene is
he's on the phone with the hostage
takers right and he's like I have a very
particular set of skills that could be a
nightmare for people like you and then
he never says what they are they know
it's bad like if it was me I'd be like I
have a very particular set of skills
that could be a nightmare for people
like you Microsoft Word Microsoft Excel
powerpoints I'm a people person I could
be a nightmare if you're looking for a
mid-level receptionist position I don't
know what microsoft access is it's
always on my computer I opened it one
time I got frightened and I closed it
should I hang up you hang up
should i okay don't kill my daughter I I
hung out with my mom recently and my mom
is like super Jewish which means she's
completely lost track of valid things to
worry about and we were going inter we
were going into her friend's house for a
dinner right and this is true she
stopped me before we go in and she goes
like this I forgot to tell you just so
you know my friend's son is a failed
magician and I'm letting you know so you
don't bring up magic the whole night
yeah I don't just bring up magic for no
reason but she should have said anything
because now all I wanted to do was
awkwardly bring up magic the whole night
okay go and I was like hey nice night
out I guess you could say it's a magical
evening oh you're a terrible magician
I'm gonna go to the bathroom and
disappear for a second oh how do I
become a comedian I was a writer and
then abracadabra there I was I'm not
invited back Thanks okay thank you very
much Barry Rothbart
[Applause]